[Musique]
c'est le printemps pour tout le monde
dans l'oeil des vaches le sceau de la
grenouille la toilette allègre du castor
[Musique]
et
c'est l'autre at on également pour lui
les lapins aussi mais méfiez vous de cet
accès irrésistibles de bonne humeur qui
nous pousse à faire n'importe quoi
n'importe où il ya des choses qui sont
interdites ça par exemple même sur un
trottoir même devant chez vous
[Musique]
ça aussi même si ce sont vos compagnons
favoris et qu'ils ne sont pas méchants
on n'avait pas le droit non plus de vous
promener avec une nouvelle garde
par contre quel que soit votre âge vous
pouvez choisir des costumes qui font
plus jeune et vous avez parfaitement le
droit également de tenter votre chance
et quelle chance
mais choisissez bien votre endroit pour
le premier bain en plein air et ne vous
mettez surtout pas en colère si quelques
gouttes de pluie vienne troubler votre
soleil pour tomberiez dans les
interdictions
[Musique]